this is what Lego products looked like
in the 1980s
and this is a Lego Product now
that's because the company has become
more than just blocks they have video
games movies theme parks all these
activities which ultimately reinforce
the core which is the sale of Lego sets
all that content helped it become the
role
breaking in billions of dollars every
year here's how the company uses
licensing deals and media to expand its
customer base and build its content
Empire this is the economics of
Lego Lego is 90 years old it was founded
in Denmark in 1932 and initially it was
a company that made wooden toys but then
in the 1950s it launched its trademark
product to the one we all know now that
the plastic logo brick since then Lego
has beat out Hasbro and Mattel to become
the biggest toy brand worldwide in the
first six months of 2022 the company's
Revenue hit 27 billion Danish kroner or
about 3.47 billion dollars up 17 from
2021 and its anticipating growing demand
so much so that the company is building
two new factories in the US and Vietnam
Lego has made the bricks the building
blocks of its business Lego is still
essentially a toy company what they
always say is their core is still to
make the plastic bricks for kids but of
course they do now do a lot more than
that some of LEGO's first moves into
content started in the 1990s
when the company's sales slumped it was
trying everything from new toys to
electronics to theme parks can you find
the power
Bionicle Bionicle came along in the
early 2000s and that was a time when the
LEGO brand was actually in danger of
becoming a little bit stale the Bionicle
franchise featured buildable action
figures and multi-platform storytelling
agile determined Unstoppable the
franchise built a Content Universe
through Comics books movies and video
games the BET proved successful in 2003
when the toymaker saw 26 loss in net
sales Bionicle was its best-selling line
and it really revitalized the brand and
and showed them a way that they could
engage audiences with different types of
content with cartoons movies
comics and it wasn't just Original
Stories Lego released its first sets
based off of licensed material in 1999.
Star Wars in 2005 it brought that into
content with a five minute short called
revenge of the brick that aired on
Cartoon Network
it was a Twist of course on the Revenge
of the Sith which was the the Star Wars
movie which came out at the time that
really paved the way for the for the
content Partnerships which we've seen in
subsequent years that Lego twist has
since been put to use on all sorts of
franchises like Batman Marvel and
Jurassic world really we're now used to
seeing not just the basic logo kits but
Lego Star Wars kits and and so on that's
really an integral part of what Lego
does now so it's really the content has
changed Lego's identity we think of it
as part of these popular franchises
which we all know like Marvel and
licensed material was on full display on
the company Smash Hit 2014's The Lego
Movie which grossed over 450 million
dollars worldwide it held the top spot
in the U.S box office for three weeks
after its release Superman Wonder Woman
the mirror made Michelangelo and the
2002 NBA All-Stars the goal of the Lego
movie was to Market Lego to a wider
audience I think it was a lot more more
successful than anyone imagined it was a
very successful movie in its own right a
big hit at the box office that laid the
template for for a lot of the content
creation that Lego has done since then
Lego and Warner Brothers released three
more feature films the latest in 2019.
none earned as much as the first of
course there is a risk of oversaturation
Lego doesn't want to do too much but but
I think they're still very much at the
stage of growing in a lot of markets
content has helped the toy maker break
into new places like China where Lego is
growing its presence of the 66 new
stores it opened in the first half of
2022 46 of those were in China almost 42
percent of the company's 833 locations
are there movies and games assist in
raising awareness of the brand the main
challenge Lego is faced in in New
Markets like China is that the grown-ups
of parents just don't really know about
Lego they don't have Lego in their in
their own backgrounds like a lot of
grown-ups in in the US and Europe do and
using licensed material in that content
also helps reach more audiences being
part of these popular franchises like
The Avengers for example is a great way
for Lego to to reach out to
all kinds of different Generations
people across the world people who don't
necessarily even know Lego content is
also a way for it to appeal to its adult
fans as the brand has been trying to do
in recent years find your flow build
with Lego bricks reality TV show Lego
Masters for example features adults
building extreme Creations out of the
titular plastic bricks the original Lego
fans took to Lego as kids and they're
now grown up and and a lot of those
people are still very keen on Lego and I
think Lego very smartly realizes that a
lot of those people would be willing to
to buy kits that are pretty complex
pretty expensive and are designed
specifically for for grown-ups the
company has its eye set Beyond just the
two-dimensional screen last April Lego
and epic games announced a partnership
to build a digital experience in the
metaverse all of this content certainly
in the company's current thinking that
movies the games that all is there to
support the core product which is the
same as it has been for decades the
plastic brick